aber ich finde es eigentlich eher cooler
wenn du was am untergrund tun würdest
über übertragen
das obwohl ein witz - das ist etwas erst
doch jetzt wohl rechtlich der ernst das
ist doch wohl ein einlenken mein leben
fallen dann herzlich willkommen zurück
zu einer weiteren folge minecraft hero
immer noch zusammen mit hedos zu der
zone und ich werde in dieser folge einen
tollen show koberstein und endlich mal
mein haus zu ende bauen und
wahrscheinlich auch im untergrund ein
bisschen james und nicht untergrund mal
jedes mal schreibt wenn ich da jetzt
hinsetzen
babbel ich brauche mal will auf jeden
fall dass wir natürlich nicht raus
kleidung jetzt mal auf jeden fall hätte
riesige spyder
sie sind zur riesenparty to und krieger
explodiert
ob das oder ist ja okay ich brauche ja
das ist jetzt natürlich in redwood dass
die sache da lücken sind im haus naja
ich hab das auch nur wenn ich rum
bringen während des versuchs irgendwie
gut mit den zuschauern zu sprechen ja
auf jeden fall ich brauch mal will nikon
sowie company wie komme ich jetzt an
marta von rachel her
man kann eben kinos gefunden so von
meiner seite aus ich bin immer noch ein
bisschen netter da werde ich mich an
revanche denken aber es hat ein paar
mops es nervt ja was denn dann
luca kleiner pisser jetzt warum dieser
hielt lukas hallo entschuldigung bitte
zurück also ich mache eine kleine
pressebericht an dann hole ich mir mein
haus weiter so etwa jeder dritte zu
wenig wissen ja dass ich mit r bergmann
kurze zeit lang unterrichtet habe also
wir haben ja beide an einer schule an
einer schule quasi unser unserer
anerkennungsjahr oder das heißt ja nicht
wirklich an unsere batterie abgemacht
anerkennungsjahr was das und ja da haben
wir längere zeit zusammen und richtet
das war auch eine ganz schöne zeit zu
machen
unsere aufnahme folgen finde ich das
findbuch softer creeper wieso weil diese
absender zurück zurückschießen ich hab
grad ebene ich habe auf den körper
geschossen und das war so ein job und
dann hat sich auf den geschossen hat er
sich zu mir teleportiert instant
explodiert ich hab das gefühl
also ich bin halt schon halbtot das
eigentlich jetzt hier drauf ziele mit
der lew dass ich jetzt jeden moment bin
doch nicht aber ein bisschen durch die
gegend und ist richtig witzig spritzig
von anleihen diese blöde mob falle alter
dazu steht drin los ist
auch mano gut egal echtzeit meinem eines
geld an die braut strahlte eine boshaft
sein weil sprossen scale
es kann zudem boss deutlich verlangsamen
alter das thema mega scheiße alter also
ich bin hier einfach ein bisschen insel
und das macht echt spaß das zu erkunden
ich weiß gar nicht warum luca
damit der lakonisch alter aber ich finde
es eigentlich eher cooler wenn du was am
untergrund tun würdest über übertragen
das obwohl witz kinos das ist etwas erst
jetzt wohl echt nicht der ernst das ist
doch wohl nein du bist echt schals wo
soll ich dich holen
das ist doch wo bist du gestorben
nicht okay ist genauso wir in der micro
feld sagst in minecraft in der hölle
irgendwo keine ahnung 900 irgendwas oder
so einen scheiß siehst du das jetzt
nicht die koordinaten ein wo bist du
denn vom portal aus lang laufen
wo haben wir behaupten portal dahinten
habe im portal screen erkläre mir das
mal kannst du deine aufnahme an gucke
mir sagen irgendwie wahrscheinlich nicht
dann mache ich kurz die die minecraft
aufnahme aus dann hört man nicht kurz
nicht
leute ich krieg' ich krieg das große
abkürzen gerade eben ja der kinder
kriegt das große abkürzen gerade eben
was soll das denn ich habe mein bild nur
weist normalerweise hatte ich bisher
immer immer eine blöde fehler dabei eine
goldene feder damit mir genau sowas
nicht passiert dann stehe ich an einem
abgrund deckte schon habe ich jetzt
darunter fall wäre das aber doof und
dann kommt so ein behinderter
geistesgestörter zombie pigment von
hinten und denkt sich was soll das seine
sachen einfach vor zwei folgen hab ich
gesagt auch ja alle fünf folgen sterbe
ich übrigens so was habe ich denke ich -
833 266 warte minus 233 266 mal nicht so
weit weg - 238 - 833 und 266
das ist doch moment jetzt schalte ich
mal gleich wieder dazu damit würde ich
auch wieder hört erfahren so man lieber
luca man hört ja freude
freudig ich kann aber sagen dass ich
wahrscheinlich gleich bei den sachen
denn das ist so wohl echt das ist doch
also jetzt mal jetzt mal ganz das ist so
langsam nicht mehr witzig 8000 mal diese
blöden hunger und das spinnen alter dann
natürlich sie das mega- spinnen und
alles lief gut und nein ich habe nur
einmal meine goldene feder meinem alltag
ist dies seit 50 folgen nie richtig
gebraucht hat dass wir tatsächlich
gestorben
es kotzt mich an okay okay sagt noch mal
die erste koordinate menschenrechte hier
am - 833 266 833 man gefurzt ich furze
vor wut ich habe deine sachen judokas
auch ein grabstein war keiner da doch
ablenken abstand ja gut da kann ich
wenig wiederbelebt werden und dann haben
die linie kommt dann zum ersatz auf
meinem kanal der runde minecraft pvp mit
so hast du in gold schwert am start
alter weil ich das gefunden habt
vielleicht deine brüste müsste es da
noch an haben jedenfalls zur erklärung
bauen kommt dann auf meinem kanal
minecraft für vp stadt minecraft hero
logischerweise weil ich der applaus
sperre ab zusammen mit dem song contest
habe ich da einfach unten aufgenommen
ich glaube ende games ist es also da
gibt es ersatz aber das ist doch wohl
echten b2c vor zwei episoden sagen och
ja jetzt mal den schrittmacher ich
sterbe alle fünf folgen weil was immer
jetzt weiß man jetzt luca
ich gehe auf den rechner so wir gehen
auf 62 folgen geteilt durch zwölf tode
so jetzt im moment das kann nicht
stimmen
20 folgen total durch 12 ich bin immer
noch bei 57 steht ja gar nicht runter
gedrückt
doch wo waren jetzt das portal
daneben ist er spielt in einer höhle
gefangen oder wie das hier läuft
ich sage dir wo das portal ist man ja
ich hab das portal aber das kriege ich
jetzt so dafür dass dich durch grund mit
drin belebt gefälligst einen gründer
wieder
ich würde mein spiegel etwa hier
benutzen
ja genau
traurig dass ich dich jetzt retten muss
in einer folge wo ich eigentlich ein
haus bauen heute ja das ist traurig dass
das ist alles traurig was du die nächste
frage die kann ich damit aufnehmen
doch was ich konnte gab ständig
mitnehmen meint aber voll im moment das
ist so das sind innerhalb von 10
sekunden sind und gefühlte 100 todes
fantasien mit ihr durch meinen kopf
gerüttelt und wenn ich nachher mich den
gepflegten korridors widmen kann ich
wieder join nein jedoch starb für den
übergang jedoch brand ich mir nicht
gesprungen diese von einem kombi widmen
von hinten gestoßen so wie du jeden
zweiten mittwoch werde er in innsbruck
ist ja da kannst du auf komme ich sehr
emotional text geschrieben
ich hasse hat manchmal hasse ich also
weil manchmal hasse ich dieses projekt
so schön response wahlmann bloomberg mit
ich bin ein profi
du willst ein verdammt der piste und ich
zeig euch was ich immer der beste
jedes zweite mal da
über grund ist richtig gut in seinem
gründer arzt total drauf
über grund ist richtig
ich höre viel licht in säle
du musst mitmachen
der untergrund ist richtig gut
unser gründer soll was drauf ja der
untergrund ist richtig gut in unser
gründer der etwas drauf der untergrund
filiale
das ist die beste die ich je gehört habe
die pinkey stinky mit microblogs blogs
herumgedruckst guck mal unseren tollen
dings an sonntagen kopf wurde weist den
der da beim immer grund ist der stadt
bagua day ein bärenkopf das hast du es
ja alles gemacht um sie richtig toll ich
habe ich hab dich wieder billig der
geständige steht dir da wieder rein dass
sein gehege winkel stinkt die fabrik so
viel scheiße microblogs so was was du
mein zeug reingemacht in meine kiste
aber das war ja fast nichts das waren 43
brot ich gerne wieder sei nicht arrogant
zu mir
natürlich gucken ja weißt du wie das ist
habe ich nicht gefunden
hier wurden
dankeschön also die menge an brot gehen
schade ich hab keinen moment nicht ob so
was macht ihr richtig schade nicht hören
aber den kostenlos verzaubern kann jeder
mal bei der hab ich bei so einem krassen
mob gekriegt in der in der pyramide im
lama ding kann man ihn vielleicht
kostenlos
wir bezahlen schreibt meine kommentare
ob sich dieser feier speer in
irgendeiner art und weise lohnt weil ich
weiß es nicht
klasse ansage von mir oder hälfte hätte
sondern auch mit dynatrace ort das muss
noch nicht mal wieder irgendwie geil
digger jetzt noch mal wieder gut und
traf auch seine waffe gestorben
wie kann man das färben halte ganze mir
kann's mir übrigen würde mal ein schwert
wiedergeben das finden platz rheingold
schwert das sind alles wäre alles cool
gold wert so weit kann ich dennoch
verzaubern
ich muss noch ein bisschen mehr op
werden eigentlich als standard auf
packen soll
ich gehe ein bisschen mobbing was ist
denn gut für den bogen noch da ist doch
das heftigste dorfes geht doping mobbing
rottbeck scheiß egal ob beck konnte
sogar komplett am computer packen bei
aspect fokus auf kfz stil war jetzt
einfach mal drauf nee ich verzaubert die
beim eine rüstung das ist es nämlich
jungs
seit erst mal das hier da kommt noch nie
irgendwas hatte noch nicht protection
vier protection 4 production vier data
protection 2 da kommt protection 43
protection 4 sitzt du dich eigentlich
auch manchmal als würdest du wohl nix
reißen wenn du siehst es zum beispiel
allein das kämpfen im falle gebaut
ich weiß gar nicht wie das geht heftige
tat dann schon getraut so drei immer mit
meinen teil hoffe mit meinem schwert auf
dich bauen das tötete ich ihnen ich
möchte einmal kurz gucken miete das ab
cd mp3 wenn ich erschieße ich habe gar
keinen fall dass kultig zehn mal kurz zu
fall ohne schaden alleine muss aber ganz
schön krass verzaubert oder er hat mir
gesagt hat dies aber nicht an und immer
mit stop stop ich ziehe meine skater
ausweichen zu verzaubern also nicht mehr
guck mal macht die kappe nimmt alles vom
liga boden runterholen chris teber war
guck mal wie ich einmal damit schießen
kann
das ist immer komplett angespannt aber
ich hab ihn kristlbauer aber ich mag
mein liga wo eigentlich steche dich
töten könnte leg dich nicht mit rein
gucken aber vielleicht aus einem im
küchenbau machen jetzt nicht mehr
angreifen ich bin damals zu verzaubern
so schlegel
luca
das ganze verhalten
ich google etwas restauration heißt ich
bin halt nicht meinem spiel so gut drauf
aber ich bin ja nett dann wäre ich jetzt
die folge noch professionell mit zu
verbringen heißt du nicht wird darauf
bauen sollen so was gibt es also ins
alte ann stores dornach so das ist
glaube ich wenn ich geschlagen werde
dass der andere dann irgendwie auch
schaden bekommt oder so reading
kriegsende sind spirit cool touch bold
touch
ich will dass es störte city vitality
dass man welche dass ich mir das drauf
packen soll kraft wie teuer ist das 37
ach du leute ich habe auch parabol hier
am start wobei level was hast du die man
auch an gemacht ja warum
weil er nichts kommt natürlich steht
auch direkt davor kommt ja nix hier raus
was tust mir immer so wie das blut mein
corp eine crime scene okay wir müssen
auf jeden fall aufdecken
abgesehen von den zu fassen
so jetzt dass ich dort ja auch du am
ende das achtung ich bin ich wenn ich
hier dran bin ja dann verzaubert was
dann hab ich meine rüstung
möglicherweise nicht komplett an
ok hast du dort jetzt hast du das
verstanden hast du das eigentlich jetzt
verstanden hast du das verstanden hast
du das verstanden heftig könntest du ich
könnte ich dich zerstören könnte
glücklich dass dort wird getötet hat
weltweit für wirbel um liegt also aufs
ganze gesehen da draußen auf dem feld
denn was ist eigentlich auch so ja es
ist eigentlich mein haus mal weiterbauen
habe ich weiß ja aus welchem material
die decke machen soll
immer wenn ich sterbe regnet übrigens in
unserer nation hier vor oben ist auch
aus marbach moment ich bin mal kurz auf
der onyx denkmal und ich rauche kette
real was welchem material soll ich das
denn bauen manno und welche drin
die kann ich da nicht aus maribor jörg
scheiße aus die echt scheiße aus ihr
schönes haus gegeben
leute ich hab ich kein großes bauen soll
hast du das wenn ich ein haus habe und
ich hab so eine grobe idee aber ich weiß
nicht wie ich das umsetzen soll holen
doch man alter was mache ich denn jetzt
da oben wollte ich auf jeden fall gas
hinsetzen was ich jetzt mache ich töten
schaaf schon ende mai
mal kraftvoll wachsen aber ich hab's
befolgt drücke es euch richtig stark
gemacht
mit den änderungen und ein kritikpunkt
dann kann ein tier hin dass geräusche
glaubt nicht dass das komisch geräte bay
logisch also jetzt ja noch zwei wegen
dieser blöden dohrmann dpa das tolle
chancen ab heute gar nicht mehr erholen
dann mach einfach immer intakt dann ist
das sofort gras anstatt erde wo ich
stehe änderte man es war irgendwo
dahinten oder wo ich hier sehe habe ich
nach münchen habe ich dir mach ich finde
nicht mehr eigentlich egal warum steht
ja nicht so dass ich fragte ob ich türen
habe du ja hier kann ich nicht
beantworten ob du mit deiner cousine
schlafendes oder nicht hast du da google
dürftig wie schnell jeder fall schnell
das mal synonym für den einkauf hat sich
nochmal kaufen müsse nur das böse
klett.de ich musste was einkaufen
ja und wir müssen schluss machen nee ich
will nicht schluss machen ja müssen wir
aber leider geht es nicht mehr anders
ja es geht nicht mehr anders sonst uns
sonst merkt das recht der kinder weiß
ich so goldene feder hab ich wieder drin
damit wäre es mit dieser folge von
minecraft hero wie gesagt dass mal
wieder jetzt jetzt könne wieder mit
lights bewertung da lassen durch
sadistisch darüber freuen hhg das ist
gestorben ein land
luca gerettet deswegen liebt mich ja
nicht genau genau liebt ihn tief im wald
hat mich jeder gerettet ich bin zu die
todes bildstein gibt es bei minecraft vp
beim luca wahrscheinlich ganz normalen
hero und damit wieder und wunderschönen
tag